no big deal virgin river is just
becoming a global phenomenon now that
season four is out how does it all feel
for you
it's uh it's a little surreal um
for sure
it's always surprises me every season it
seems we get a little bit bigger
um
and and
we go to work and we kind of look at
each other because usually we can't make
it down the street without someone being
like oh brady or um which it's it's
jarring at first but then you know we're
just so appreciative of everyone and it
seems uh
it seems like it's really resonating
with people um which is amazing uh it's
a feel-good show so it's making people
feel good and then wonderful
what do most people say when they
recognize you
you know the first thing is they said i
used to hate you
but now i really like you um and and and
so i'm like that's good that's good
you're you're forgiving you've got an
open mind that that's wonderful um
but uh yeah it's a fun arc i get to play
with brady i took him from this kind of
uh
antagonistic
um bad boy to really kind of someone
who's just misunderstood and has a lot
of layers that you know
that i was able to open up over the
seasons
is it more fun playing the bad guy
i get asked this a lot is it more fun
playing the bad guy yes a hundred
percent that's way more fun um you get
to do the badass things you know you get
to like
fight people and you get to like get the
girl and you get to be
you ride the motorcycle those are the
cool things right and so you know often
as an actor if you play the leading guy
who's the hero you can't do certain
things you can't make certain choices as
an actor it's freeing to be the bad guy
because you
you can do whatever you want i get when
i get to work i get to do whatever i
want uh when in terms of the scene which
is really fun for me um and i have a lot
of freedom within that realm so that's
that's that's great
you basically get to live out all your
fantasies
yes all
fantasies are lived out um
you know as growing up you know it was
like it's a lot of tom cruise uh top gun
vibes of that like
you know maverick type of character um
that you grow up watching in the 90s
that like bruce willis the you know
everyone loved those and i wasn't i was
no exception i grew up watching these
guys and you know i embody some of them
and brady for sure
what do you think it is about virgin
river that just has audiences you know
coming back season after season in
droves
that's a great question i you know um i
think it has a lot to do with the
community i think that's one thing that
we have been yearning for as a society
since the whole pandemic started which
is kind of when our show really became
popular and a huge chit
people wanted to be a part of this town
that this fictional town which
everyone kind of comes together and
supports each other and it reminds
people i think of a time where we all
used to live in like a bit of harmony
and it wasn't this big division between
people and there weren't these
really intense social and economical
issues and and geopolitical issues and
and i think
as important as it is to address all
those issues and to be aware of all
those issues i think it's equally
important important for us to like have
a reprieve from them and
be able to unwind it at the end of the
night and
feel warm and fuzzy and you know um
i think that's why this is doing so well
i think it's a bit of it's almost like
um entertainment medication
you know i need i need uh i need to take
two episodes of virgin river tonight
with some wine and
some cheese plate that's what i that's
what i need uh and and sometimes that's
okay you know um
it's definitely something i've done
before and i've you know caught uh
become my neighbors doing it actually
season four um funny story i was walking
out to the car
and i was getting something out of the
car and i look over to my neighbor's
house
and they've got virgin river playing uh
it was like the day after we came out so
it was the scene where spoiler alert uh
brady gets stabbed um and so we know
that them well obviously and i walked up
to their their patio they had this big
glass patio and they just watched me die
like literally not die sorry stabbed
that was not a spoiler um
and i like was like
they freaked out jumped off the couch
and uh yeah they were totally caught
red-handed watching their neighbor on tv
i love that i mean follow up to that i
was laughing at that billboard that you
posted on instagram
why do you think moms are falling in
love with this show mine included
yeah i'd say does seem to be a lot of
moms doesn't it um
you know what i think it has to do
with
the romance i think that um
you know if you're a mom you obviously
fell in love with a guy and
you know you had some sexy time
and uh
uh you know i i think that that is
obviously something that you cherish and
and you don't forget and sometimes it's
nice to be reminded of that um
regardless of what stage in life you are
to be reminded those early stages where
the twinkle and everything is still new
and and jack and mel embody that bree
and brady embody that and uh it's
exciting even for me to play it because
it reminds me of my own relationship and
those early days of
the excitement of never really knowing
what's next and exploring all these new
firsts and so
um i think there's a bit of nostalgia
for moms out there
but i will say with that billboard i got
so many dads and like non-moms giving so
much jade it was
it was hilarious like what about the
debt what about the debt what about the
fur moms or the the dog moms and you
know it was the whole the whole gambit
so um
yeah watch out netflix because i bet you
that that billboard on sunset boulevard
got some hate mail it's gonna get torn
down by the fur moms
because my family jokes well like if i
call my mom and i need advice about
something she'll start giving me advice
says you know there was this one woman
and she'll like go into this story i'm
like is this the plot of virgin river
again or is this actually someone you
knew
so it really has them in a absolute
chokehold right now
it's great it's like uh so i would like
to give the advice of uh season three
episode four where
right i mean it's it's built-in advice
learn from this do this this works
exactly yeah how
has changed since this show blew up
you know what um yeah aside from getting
stopped even with a hat and a mask on
it's amazing it's amazing how people are
very very
sharp when it comes to spotting me out
in the in the community um
but
you know i think the biggest thing that
shifted for me
um
was being a part of this family it's all
really tight
we're
a community not just on the screen but
we're a community off the screen
and it's really nice to be a part of
that and um you know and i'm not just
talking about the actors the the crew
members the people that don't really get
the stopped on the street because
they're but they're a part of the
success of the show and we get to go to
work often the first few weeks of work
coincide with the previous season's
launch so we go to work with each other
and there's this shared you know um
success that we all get to you know um
be a part of and and really enjoy
together so
um that's been that's been life-changing
and a lot of fun
you said you're shooting season five
right now obviously i know there's not a
ton you can give away but what can fans
expect from brady
oh um yes okay without getting
assassinated by my producer um
i can say that um
it's going to be i'm going to be cryptic
here okay um because that's the best way
to do it um
it's going to be dangerous for brady
again it's going to be uh hot and steamy
but not in the very brady sense of hot
and steamy so um take from that what you
will
and um you know there might be some
reconciliation or repairing of
relationships as well so uh yeah i can
say all that i think without having to
dodge a bullet
why do you think brady and bree work so
well
you know it's funny i think um i think
the best couples
they complement each other so where
someone might not be able to get
somewhere on time
the uh spouse my wife gets me there on
time or you know in green brady's case
you know where um
where
brady might be a little um um you know
rough around the edges or or uh very uh
impulsive i think bree is very
calculated and
polished and i think that
that really works and obviously there's
a physical attraction there which is
very important in the relationship
and so i do really think that they have
this yin and yang thing
that i think is really important for
success for a successful couple
i think it's been incredible too seeing
the softer side of brady come out is
that going to continue a bit are fans
going to get to see a bit more of the
walls come down
yeah well i mean they really did
in season three and four you got to see
this guy who
seemed to be
so closed off and
and um
you know misunderstood you really
started to understand that you started
to get where he had this
you know chip on his shoulder from with
not having the father figure and having
his his childhood be so um you know
difficult
but then you get to see him
emotionally and mentally grow from that
you know uh having
bree and having love often does that to
people you know changes them usually and
hopefully for the better
and brady was no different as he fell in
love with bree he opened up he
became
um
a new better version of brady 2.0 if you
will
he really started to
look at life through a different lens
and and and one that's empathetic and
one that you know um
was a little more vulnerable and open
and for me that's a lot of fun to play
when i can take a character that is an
antagonistic
um
you know
bad boy off the start and i can slowly
peel away the layers to expose who he
really is at the core
that's that's the best gift possible as
an actor because you can you can keep
keep that back from them and slowly
release it in little parts and as an
audience member i think that's really
rewarding too you feel like you really
get to know someone that way
you've had such incredible jobs but
you're also the father to three children
is that the most rewarding job would you
say
yeah that's the hardest one for sure and
definitely the most rewarding i always
say this i say i think the best things
in life are also the most difficult
things um the things we work hard at uh
are the most rewarding and for me i work
really hard at being a good dad um if
i'm not you know if i'm not
if i'm shooting on location or if i'm
away from the boys and i now have a
third so the kids i have a daughter now
um
then i you know i try and read them a
bedtime story over zoom or um i try and
be there for them uh even when i am at
work
but uh the reward for me is coming in
the door and seeing these three
i gotta say as far as fans go they're my
three biggest fans uh
um and coming running at me with hugs
and kisses and you know there's um
i may not get an oscar for this role but
um
i certainly get my share of rewards
you